hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
I am at the Samsung booth at CES 2014
you guys told me you wanted to see their
new tablets so they have the Galaxy Note
pro which is a twelve point two inch
tablet but they also have three new
Galaxy Tab pros and 8.4 inch a 10.1 inch
and a twelve point two inch so this is
the whole new Pro Series lineup that's
been introduced here at CES no there's
no galaxy s5 here and there's definitely
known who Nexus 10 here as much as I
would love it to be but these are
actually some interesting tablets and it
seemed like a lot of you guys were
curious too so take a look here of
course they have all the same full other
back and stitching as the Galaxy Note
3's and they actually kind of feel the
same way in the hand including the
difference between colors and black
versus white and the series is of course
a whole range of screen sizes as I
mentioned as Samsung likes to do but you
don't really realize how big a 12 point
2 inch tablet is into to get some
perspective so here it is here's the
Galaxy Note 3 as we know that's a 5.7
inch display and then we have the Galaxy
Tab pro 8.4 with of course an 8.4 inch
display then the Tab pro 10.1 and I can
guess what the the final screen size is
the Tab pro 12.2 which is the same size
as the note Pro they have a twelve point
two inch display pretty massive now I
guess the next logical question is
what's the difference between the Tab
pro 12.2 and the note pro that's the
same size and people have Samsung that I
spoke with basically just said the
stylus that's the that's the difference
it's just the stylus so the Galaxy Note
pro is essentially a Galaxy Tab pro 12.2
plus the stylus and the stylus features
which have me curious to see if that
might actually cost more but at least
one advantage of having such a large
tablet with a 12 point 2 inch display is
that you get a full-sized QWERTY
keyboard and Samsung is really proud of
that and demoing it on as many tablets
as they could but that's just the 12
point 2 inch but really these are Pro
Series tablets so Samsung is antha
sizing the multitasking features in fact
these larger ones actually allow for 4
way multitasking mode that lets you drag
an app to each corner of the display
and use them all at the same time same
way as you could on the note 3 except
now you have four and that's actually
really useful with all these screen real
estate so this Plus Samsung's floating
window means you actually can probably
get some serious work done with multiple
applications open at the same time or so
at least they claim and this is all in
the new TouchWiz on top of Android 4.4
KitKat on all these tablets and you can
kind of tell by the great color scheme
and the notification bar and by some
other subtle changes but really it's all
about TouchWiz again and you could
probably never tell what version of
Android it's running if you didn't check
but the notification bar is the biggest
change I noticed it's way more colorful
and bold which is pretty amazing
considering how colorful and bold
TouchWiz was in the first place and
there's also a new whole tablet UI with
all these panels that reminds me a lot
of chameleon which was a launcher on
Android earlier that allowed you to move
around and resize the different panes
this basically does the same thing on a
sort of a TouchWiz colorful level but
other than that the new hardware was
pretty much what we'd expected out of
Samsung there were unfortunately no
front-facing speakers to be found on any
of these tablets but something really
really nice is that they all have 2560
by 1600 displays including the 8.4 inch
tab pro which i think makes it the
highest pixel density in any midsize
tablet form factor the rest of them are
up to 1080p so that's really nice and it
also has an 80 200 million power battery
to power it all and it's not really all
that thick as a high-end processor two
gigs of ram sounds like a really nice
device and of course I need to get my
hands on it and test it for myself to
know but if it's actually as good as it
seems I'm pretty excited for the Tab pro
8.4 oh and also these pro series tablets
all have sim cards so you could
technically make phone calls from them
if you're into that but either way
that's minute guys I was actually really
excited to see these new tablets the pro
series even though the note and Tab
series aren't going anywhere because
these are the first devices running
Android 4.4 KitKat and that have
TouchWiz on top of them so we'll likely
see a lot of these new improvements
maybe not the multitasking but a lot of
the enhancements in something like the
galaxy s5 when it comes out this year
with Android 4.4 KitKat on that so
that's our little sneak peek at the new
TouchWiz on phones but either way that's
been it so let me know what you guys
think of them thanks for watching
talk to you guys in the next one peace
[Music]